[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic expert guest this week is
Tony Sol who's the founder of generating
genius which is a charity that helps
inner-city kids get to top universities
here in the UK Tony welcome to
trigonometry thanks for having me the
question we always like to ask at the
beginning is how are you where you are
what's been your journey through life
well I suppose I mean my journey is an
interesting one because it's um I think
it sort of defines really for me what
what's happening down and then I look
back at that past and see it kind of a
line going in I think the line was
always how do I kind of disrupt what is
given for me so for example I was given
a crap school yeah crap Secondary School
where all of us were expected well what
happened was quite interesting that the
white kids in the school went and got
jobs usually with their uncles or
whatever or friends and there those
connections and it seems to me that's
quite interesting how they got work the
black boys in this school well we had a
hard harder time I mean a lot of us were
unemployed but I'm and really the way
out for us
this is a boys school was was hard I
would admit that this was back in in the
70s yeah and I think that I think for me
the route then became almost how do i
how do I now kind of redefine myself in
this in this interesting situation where
nothing was really happening I remember
I used to bunk off school basically to
go to the library educate myself
that was my rebellious Lee go down to
the library try to get some things but
my mother was quite smart on this one so
what she did was she and there was three
of us my brother and my sister she
packed us off quite early too and
Anglicans and can church you know it was
a high Anglican desert no one and it was
I mean angry Church of England and and
in a very middle-class scene all-white
city and so he just went in there and we
were we were the token black kids in
that in that church but there were
really nice people and they you know
they we did nice things but what was
interesting was it changed our
perception because suddenly we had a I
think for it for I always look at this
for anybody as a sort of adolescent
growing up your peer groups gonna define
a lot of who you are and how you work
you know in that and and so in a sense
we were subtly given this new peer group
of middle-class kids and they went off
to university and they came back in in
the summer and so okay they were armed
they were our new friends and so that's
what you do now cuz in our schools
nobody went to university but for us
that that was a changes alright I want
to be like my friends so I better go
after University so we we go we will
tell you about how we gonna do this
because we need scrapped schools how we
gonna get there and and so we just
suppose but it's quite interesting that
that didn't seem to be that difficult
and I I say that because if you're so
some of this stuff is about motivation
is about that drive in to do something
is there obviously you do need to have
some of the stuff in place but to be
socially mobile a lot of it and that
that's why I began to think about social
mobility that a lot of it was quite
intrinsic yeah and so therefore that set
us off on that journey or me on that
journey to sort of go off the university
and and and I think ever since then I've
always had the tension between almost
like middle class people trying to sort
of work out what I am and who I am and
and and and and that kind of desire to
do something different
so for example if you I remember going
to I mean I I'm also defined by my
Jamaican background as well my parents
was in Jamaica and I and then and all of
that was very important in the 70s for
us and and but it wasn't the sole sole
thing that defined me you know I had
another part of me which was I don't
know just another part of me I like I
love classical music for example I love
bark and things like that and I remember
going to the south bank and the I don't
know if you remember this band called
Osibisa did I remember there was an
African band they were playing on one
corner and then they were there in the
Purcell rooms but was playing another I
got my ticket to go to the first room
and I remember the guy the guy at the
door actually blocking me from the BART
concert say that you got girls to do
this because that's one of black people
yeah you say that but he just said what
we in there you know because what it
might have been something was gonna harm
me if I was good because I was gonna
video I was about 17 and the someone was
gonna someone was gonna harm me if I was
gonna go in there listen to Barnea
I'm gonna go jump up with all the other
black people in Ibiza that's really and
if you like that kind of thing was
continually kind of you go in you go in
as um this just one of the reason why
I'm adamant about this is I had a recent
interview with The Sunday Times yeah
which I I don't know slam the journalist
but I'm it was a good interview now we
have some offices in central London it
just happened that by PA she booked her
office which was I mean it was a very
small room yeah and it was and she
brought her intern in there so there was
three of us in the room and we were
talking and I was relaxed as you can see
I've got a South London accent i i'm i'm
hopefully I'm fairly articulate with you
I'm comfortable with my accent I love my
South London back
you may say you cracked on you anyway
when I read the piece after we had dud
this of her thing was I'm 6 foot 2 I'm a
mess of me I don't think I'm I don't
know if I'm that kind of intimidate in
any way her first comment was we're in
this cramped room with Tony who has a
massive frame and a raspberry Croydon
accent you know and that was the first
definition of so I was kind of wondering
and it reminds me of the scene I never
see a Mel Brooks's Blazing Saddles
because there's a black sheriff who
comes into town no book is very good at
sort of usurping things and the sheriff
comes into they have a that they've
killed the existing sheriff so I knew
one comes you but this is sort of like
in the backwoods of Western and of
course the new sheriff is a black guy
coming in town and so he gets up with
the stage and starts addressing the
audience and then puts his hand just
slightly down to where his dick is and
then suddenly all the women go as if
something terrible's gonna happen that
kind of scene reminded me of that
because I said what was wrong with her
I've been and then of course all my
friends and it's quite interesting they
missed the article and they just went
straight for that just say well Tony
what was wrong with this woman I wrote
to her and I said to her look you know I
didn't really I didn't understand you
distract you detracted from the other
bits in them please by just saying that
and she said oh no no we have to always
set a context for our guests you know
the other piece in this case the context
was that you're black kind of
working-class ting which I think are
working-class people get I I wore a nice
suit yeah in there cuz I wanted that I
want us to get a nice sharp shot for our
charity
and I had some patent shoes I thought
they look kind of sharp so I was wearing
those as well and then she pointed to I
was wearing this push through and patent
shoes it was like you know it reminds me
of the thing in Only Fools and Horses
where Rodney's always you know the
drinks thing he has a flash drink as if
working-class people are trying to be
here
gosh I mean that kind of so it's kind of
slight that that kind of and that's a
dual thing you get and it's a very
English thing you know you on the other
hand you're a black man and it always
current
they're always obsessed with your size
and whatever and on the other hand
there's this whole kind of class thing
about your accent and what that tells
you about your accent on constantly
obsessed with it you know oh we've just
actually and I could be wrong I don't
see it happening a lot of other
countries I think the very English thing
that we do with accents and I and I can
see people continually struggling with
that at times you know in even those
people who have made it you know you can
see them always referring back to that
kind of tension so that's that was an
interesting thing but they're not you
know who cares I did quite well got a CV
from Prince Charles he was alright
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's sort of part of the journey and
then um yes well let's talk about
generating genius because you you've
talked about being stereotyped and on
what you're just talking about there but
actually you're someone who who talks
extensively about the fact that in terms
of educational outcomes and things like
that
it's not racism that prevents people
from advancing though it's a lack of
values or like a father's and them tell
us a little bit about yeah I mean the
thing isn't it still is even though that
story because it's not done
I'm here to sort of cry and about racism
or about worries me I actually think
that we we can talk about that and we
can go over that but you you have to you
accept the reality is that the society
has problems but it's not gonna hold you
back you know that's my mother's
actually and that was that was how we
what what I find is in the balance of
things I still would say that what we
what we do need is is is is this sort of
almost a kind of kind of sense to tell
young people that they've got the age of
the agency to actually kind of get over
this it's not it's not insurmountable
you should have to face it on the other
hand it's it's and it's certainly not as
bad as it was in the 70s and 80s
so there's actually progress in the
slide well one of one of the problems in
in all of this is that if you don't say
that then young people get locked in to
a world and they they feel they can't
get out of it
hence the title generate ingenious
because if you if you go if you surround
poor people or people who are oppressed
with this sort of sense that they can do
yeah so generate engine G genius is
always kind of sense of it's out there
but you can just anybody can become a
genius read you have to put the things
together the opportunities and then you
can fly yeah so what I did is I also
wanted to prove to myself that that that
formula was true and so I did is I found
the the group that was and that was
black boys who would who were actually
under achieving the worst in that in in
the society at the moment at that time
and it's improved to a certain extent
now in terms of school outcomes and
exclusions and I wanted to set them a
task to say right can you can I get a
group all the way through from the the
poorest backgrounds all the way through
to say Imperial College or Oxford
University and let's not do let's do not
do an easy something like we did English
they say let's do some sciences yeah
stuff that it's not associated with them
okay right and in a sense there is a
sense and I say this as profanes the
society as well that you know black boys
really are like that bright read I mean
you even hear it from what some say not
really that bright
they basically best just doing a bit of
DJ and stuff like that but not they're
not really belong in the lab
rediscovering stuff you know so let's
let's find the hardest thing the thing
that isn't it was associated with them
and let's put them on that track and see
what happens so it was almost like a
laboratory experiment really for myself
and I found we started with 10 and then
we increased it to a hundred and there
were certain proved quizzes around yes
they had to be bright yeah we knew that
and had to have it interested in science
but they had to were the first in their
family to University dirt poor
backgrounds and certainly none of their
school sent anybody University in fact
more of their schools were sending them
to jail than University yeah so that was
that was the kind of setup we had and
and I got them at 14 and then really I
just worked with them and I'm looking
back now I look back at that hundred and
I would say the vast majority of them
narrow top universities they're in our
alumni if at last night we up what say
last night a couple of us and we had a a
reception for those ones who came when
there were 40 now they're 24 yeah so the
Gulf and the program how it works is you
stay with us from 14 to the point that
you're at University and we work with
you in the out-of-school space in
holidays away access just doing lots and
lots of sciences so it was like it was I
was like the Pied Piper I love this
group of black boys running around
Imperial College Cambridge now what I
did I used all my connections I had had
from my journey I just because I just
know a lot of people in that sense
because I just go everywhere and
everybody at that point wanted to help
so it was as if there was nothing really
stopping it happening you know all they
needed it was somebody in the middle to
facilitate it and I think that that's
the thinning them what's happening is
that it's not that nobody wants to do
anything for poor people nobody wants to
do anything from it's just that we can't
seem to connect we have a very difficult
way of doing this somehow stuffs over
here poor people are over here and no
one's in the middle doing the link it's
not as simple as that I know but it's
some of it is just about that yeah and
and that that can be for a number of
reasons I think
it's a lack of understanding about what
the expectations that in fact what you
can do is you can put some so for
example some of the universe's some of
the college's genuinely probably didn't
think that if you came from a poor part
of Brixton in the seventies eighties you
could get to understand so they don't go
for that well and then of course the
other worst thing is that those people
already in there don't think they can
get in there right that's worse
really in some ways so you have this
equation of nobody's like because nobody
wants do they know what again they don't
think they can get their [ __ ] and they
don't want them to come yeah yeah
poverty of ambition yeah yeah because
it's not you said if you're not
surrounded by people who aspiring to do
that then why would you aspire together
yeah and we've got a concept called
people like me which is really good it's
a simple kind of thing of bringing the
Alumni is quite powerful so you can you
imagine our new cohort or little kids
now waiting and they can see that look
that of achieves once you once it the
cycle starts going it perpetuates itself
well it sounds like an amazing thing
that you're doing from your Sunday Times
piece what you're talking about there is
the fact that you can't seem to get the
politicians to actually listen to we're
talking about I think why we're where
I've where I felt where I've kind of not
been able to engage this is because I
I've adamant that I have not gone down
the route of saying it the fault of all
this is racism I think that's really
been there and they're people who are
everything like the power has been
chasing if I'd gone on sides waving the
flag and saying all these boys are
oppressed because of systemic racism I
think I would probably get more
attention there's that ironically but I
haven't said that I've said that it is
this thing of the driver of ambition to
make it happen and yeah I I don't you
know honestly think that that is an
issue and I also think that there there
just are people who are just totally
hopeless who should be there in
positions of our
of of authority and power trying to sort
out the fact that working-class people
and not getting there right forward you
and then these are people who run these
agencies and they don't know what
they're doing
and obviously I think that that is okay
I see it in terms of universities I see
it in terms of charities I see in terms
of social agencies I don't keep going
around and I just see a lot of people
trying something but it doesn't really
it's not really working and they want
any scratch and in the end it's almost
like they say this is where it gets
really bad as Oh your problems are so
complex that they can't be solved ooh
you know I mean I hit keep hearing that
oh the problem knife crap it's too
complicated there's too many things that
we don't we haven't got any solutions
the mayor says he's gonna take 10 years
to solve it you see so in a sense the
the the solute the people who can come
to the solutions are just not at the
table and I just I don't know why that
is I mean maybe you just don't know you
buddy I don't know I mean but that's
been a problem for me and I do and I and
I why I try and push myself and I'm not
it's not me alone I'm thinking that I
know other people who should be in there
you know that place called the house of
laws for example where you've got people
who are strategically overviewing
laws and things like that but hardly any
of them sound or look like me in there
and also the answers they're not they're
not they're people who've met have some
of the answers and they're not they're
not really getting it so in a way we've
got to try and completely redefine I
think with some accepting at the moment
with the Brixton
where we're really questioning and I
like I like the disruption at the moment
people say oh this is it is horrible but
what's going on is I think people are
waking up to the fact that the so-called
experts this is it I'm not the experts
and that's that's really what's going on
here they don't know and they've managed
to get in their positions but mainly
because of who they know and I think
that's that's beginning to change now
and I'd love to see if I had a chance
just people who do know what they're
doing in that position and politically
it would be different it wouldn't
necessarily be a liberal thing it would
be different people from different
grounds coming in and really trying to
sort this out so I think that's that's
where it's been stuck in the article and
I remember reading that and I read the
article in the Sunday Times and I sort
of got when you know when you said it
because it's an issue that we touch with
tiptoe around
I've taught me to private schools in
East London and a lot of the children
that do go on to join gangs they don't
have a father figure out let me just
tell you what's happened in the unit in
in the research sector in the university
in the discourses have been happening
and the people that hold almost the
power over over our knowledge you that
you would have thought that the issue of
boys would have been a case in America
another place they they have they have
looked at this issue in England that the
literature on this is very sparse it's
hardly anything early anything I mean
you know you get some people that they
don't understand boys development we
don't understand what they're doing yet
our prisons are full of them yet they're
they're the ones that are disrupting
most of the society and yet we we carry
along with this and I think it's because
what's happened is we've had a kind of
guilt reaction in regard to feminism and
I said as I say that because what what's
actually happening here is that there's
a sort of sense that the the there's a
that women have been blocked but they've
been blocked by the wrong kind of it's
not that it's this not it's not these
type of men that really doing the
blocking you know it's the right so they
so in a sense these poor boys or black
boys getting beaten up really and then
not it's not them that's really in in
the way it's you know boys of eighths
and white boys these are these are the
boys that are really up there doing all
or the impressment so the me to movement
should go after them really and in a
sense what's actually happening is
working-class boys and black boys a read
at the bottom of the rung here and and
their only way of disrupting the society
often is is is by being violent at the
bottom so we've got this kind of
mismatched you see and and I I'm I'm I'm
all for than me to move I think there
should be a me to movement for black and
working-class boys and white
working-class why I do think they need
and one of them one of the key elements
for them is they need we need to sort of
seriously ask about the family in the
home and not just accept this idea that
fathers are allowed to walk away or be
thrown out by whoever or the courts or
wherever and not have access to those
boys why is it important for the for the
boys to have fun because it's a back to
this sort of people like me let me give
you a may give you an example from the
that's where the Caribbean communities
are very kind of interesting kind of
development if you look at the way girls
and girls in you know doing are doing
now really well in the site teenage
pregnancy is gone virtually in England
you know it's you hardly see it
it's those numbers are gone we mean
basically we've got a society now with
the girls are doing very very well
University rates for girls are just high
nearly fifty sixty percent of the
campuses the girl will be at home on a
Sunday night seeing the legs between a
mum combing her here and there they're
talking and they're talking their
business and they're they're having a
great time together cuz they're doing
girl stuff yeah and that she's got a
role model with her mum and her mother
is identifying figure the boy the little
boy can do some of that when he's small
when he's Tiny's but there's a point in
a boy's life and it doesn't really
matter if even if your arm essentially
there's six around he's got nothing to
do with this there's just a point in a
boy's life where he's gonna want to push
away from that mother figure and find
another another person yeah usually that
looks to be like the father hopefully to
carry out that kind of intimate work now
if the dad isn't there to do that job
he'll find it in other boys hence that's
why boys like to go around with each
other
and that's what it is just about
identifying with people that look like
you
and you feel an empathy with that and I
think that's that's fine
the problem is the other thing is about
boys and this is where it gets quite
controversial is that biologically we've
got if you're done if you're left
standing but right hand we've got a
strong right arm and that is that means
that physically we can do a lot of
damage our ancestors realize that that
strong arm can actually tear to pieces
of village yeah so what we've got to do
it's quite interesting knife crimes
interesting there's another thing about
the right arm you know what's that doing
you know it's it and so what that what
what the father does often and I can see
in their interactions with it their sons
is that they are like the police force
they come in and they restrain those
boys yeah
I always remember when you you you look
at the risk-taking that a man does with
his son you know he's very interested
going out there son yeah especially when
they're doing riding their bikes you
know it's like I've seen it all the time
they're stereotyped yeah you know before
what the boy falls off to but get out
come on son get out there you just fend
off you just a little bruised yeah get
on with it you know and I would
stereotype I said the workers around the
voices I just kind of like know you know
I've been oh no and they get that they
get that they get that difference yeah
that risk-taking that you want go on boy
get on with it and actually to a certain
extent the boys like that they like that
kind of sense of but they want also as
somebody there to say know thus far and
no further
and that kind of my dad used to play my
dad used to be this sort of sigh needs
to be in my in my home my mother used to
do when we had corporal punishment my
mother used to do all the beating in the
oven she used to try our best
she used to beat whatever we should be I
wish you used to give her Artur but then
my file was like the nuclear weapon you
know I mean so he would be sitting there
sort of and you knew that was the kind
of almost you know that is the kind of
thing that held everything that all all
the thing in plain if you were referred
back up there that that would be a
serious and there so she said and you
could see there was like a power thing
going on and then and then and and I
just feel that that's with the father's
that that figure of authority that is
missing so therefore it's not surprising
that you look at that I mean you just
see this from the amount of boys that
are on the street at night just not who
is actually telling them to come in I'm
looking about like 12 13 in fact
sometimes even younger than that on the
street 11:00 12:00 at night I mean I
don't know but not you ask a policeman
when the policeman picks up that son and
this might be a massive stereotype I
know but ask any policeman you were in
there for they take that boy back home
and they taking them back to a single
household yeah
there's no man in a house yeah so that
debate we can't have in England because
somebody will turn round to you and say
what you're doing is you're you're
really beating up on the single mother
and that's become a sacred thing now the
single mother so and they're looking at
us now all these men talking about it
was the same old thing so all against
women it's all of you and we're blaming
them and that's that it's not that that
if you what I'm trying to get with you
you're blaming the father's father yeah
and I'm also saying that the father
should be allowed back here now some of
them said were whoa what's what's going
on here some of those men are abusive
some of them maybe but not all of them
and they need access to it and the other
thing is I think with this is that it's
actually we need to be able to support
those mothers I get calls every week
because of what I do from single mothers
saying I can't cope with this boy doctor
saw what have you got any ideas she's
reached a point specially when he's a
teenager
now everybody knows this social workers
lawyers politicians they all know this
but nobody wants to go over that sacred
line of saying that look we can't do
this yeah can we can we have some help
here you know because we're saying that
we are in the era of super women they
can do everything they can go to work
they can raise girls yeah they can also
raise boys they can do everything so how
dare you step over on that line I think
that's where we are politically that's
what we kind of a mature discussion on
it what will happen is you'll have a
discussion and the women will turn
around and say you're just blaming us
you know or it's one where it's it's not
about this is about poverty or it's
about the fact that the boys haven't got
you know some of youth youth center to
go to or things like that which is not
the real reason why they're in this
state of of disruption they're in this
rate it's a disruption because there
isn't a restraining element at home and
you think a lot of the gang problems and
the knife problems that we're seeing in
in London and elsewhere in the country
now is a down to that yeah I know that
because I used to work for the Youth
Justice Board which was the the arming
in in the society that looked after
children who were in the youth offending
area now should be on it so it's only
about 800 kids it's not a lot of kids
you know on the on the on the sort of
real kind of serious end of it you know
and those children in the end what I did
was right I kind of went round and just
asked those boys to come on tell me what
why are you here why what was the reason
for the knife crime and two things came
out of that kind of interaction number
one there was a an admission that a
point in their lives the father leaving
or not being there is this issue yeah
and I think the other one which was
which was really interesting about them
their morality was and this this
actually was quite pertinent for black
boys
was that a lot of them pleaded not
guilty for their crime so here is a boy
he's found the knife is in the hand the
police has arrived there's a runaway the
knife is in the in the hand the blood
everything is all over him
you're a bang to rights yeah he reaches
cool and he pleads not guilty and and
what happens in the in our justice
system is if you plead not guilty you
get a longer sentence because obviously
you can't bargain if you plead guilty
then obviously the judge will take that
into consideration so they're coughing
longer sentences I was quite intrigued
to find out why it was that those boys
were saying not guilty because all the
boys I met in all those you threatening
everyone and it was say they're not
guilty what's going on and I got it then
it wasn't that it wasn't that the police
had got the facts wrong they genuinely
believed they were not guilty because
when the person disrespected them the
original offense for the knife crime
that is what they're referring to
they're saying that that person actually
did me so wrong I was justified to kill
him so there's no that so what we've got
is you've got kids locked up in this
situation men locked up who haven't got
any sense of the morality of what
they've done they actually still believe
no one's done any work on that they
actually believed that they were right
so they're actually literally not guilty
because they were justified to stab them
that's when they so when they plead to
the judge not guilty that's what they
said they're saying I'm not guilty I
didn't I was justified to do it that's
horrific it you know I mean so in their
heads blood I mean that bit of it isn't
a problem I heat the fact that at the
dance he stepped on my shoe or dis my
girlfriend or whatever it was right that
was the the crime she is you're talking
about it now I think back to my
childhood
I've been dissed in my go to your dad in
my case and you know
this is what happened like what you know
what did I do and he goes with just
don't worry about it guys a dick or
whatever you know that's what a fight so
the father gives you a sense of where
the limitations are of your retaliation
exactly Stamatis the moral development
what we're going down now is the moral
development of those boys the vacuum
that's there and I'll be honest the the
man was try and and here's another
problem with this thing about the
mothers there is a significant amount of
women who actually do really well with
their boys and take them to the top
universities and they do well and so
what happens is when you have this
conversation they roll out and they say
well we're talking about
I had five boys and I sent them all to
university super mum you know and now
but in aeterna and I said well what
about that ninety percent of other women
who are not super mum we haven't got
that capacity you know what about them
and I think that's that's the problem we
have so the society is continually
telling us that women can do it all and
men are actually useless I mean that's
really the message so how do we go about
solving this i mean i mean i think i
think that the issue for me is that the
policies around certainly around some of
the settlements for boys when it comes
to uh who has custody in terms of the
breakup of the family we've got to
review how this thing works for boys
someone has got to kind of taught some
of those judges about that i think
there's there's an issue there in terms
of because often this happens in the
family breakup that happens the other
the other the other bit is that i just
think that we need to i think that there
should be a campaign i think the mayor's
office should be having a campaign about
the fact that you know a lot of men you
can be black or white men should be
taking responsibility of their kids and
actually making that more normal thing
what what happens sometimes in some
black Kim
and we've had this in the Caribbean
community that it's actually a pride
just sort of sale I've dropped three or
four kids from all these different women
at a pride of my my manhood I've dropped
all these kids and uh well I'm not
taking care of them you didn't mean and
so what cuz the state can take care of
them yeah and that's the issue this is I
know the people who then fill the
prisons
exactly yeah so what you need that you
need almost like I said a campaign to
bring the father back in a sense not an
oppressive but you know I did that
actually that it and actually make it
not a mark of good a manhood that you've
got all these kids but in fact it's a
good man is a man it takes care of his
children I'm almost like that campaign
you know in the in the heads of our boys
that that's what is it the expectation
at the moment is just nothing you know
we don't want to go there so I would I
would love the mayor for example to pull
out a poster campaign of just just sip I
just remember walking with my daughter
in it with the buggy in the hand and
walking around and people would look at
me it's that kind of is that is a
strange thing to do but it's really the
natural thing to do I'm not that dog I
know mama carried her for nine months
yeah but I'm part of that that that that
person so I've gotta be doing my share
yeah I mean you know I mean I wouldn't
even think of anything otherwise and
it's just like you know that kind of
thing of of what does what does a man
look like you know some man would be
saying it must be there with his and I
used to be other guys you know it was
great we all be together with our
buggies you know talking to each other
and it was and it was like and they
would say the same thing people would
say or people come in and say well done
scraps that you know well done you know
you know so it's like and all people
look at it I knew the other thing is you
know the interesting issue is to do with
child abuse I I think that there's a
suspicion that men with younger children
it's not natural so it's kinda I
remember when I was in I was teaching a
little boy in a nursery a one-to-one the
mother wanted me to do
sort of private lessons and and and and
she was the owner of the nursery and
then of course the mothers came in you
know as if I was kind of a good and so
there's a kind of nervousness about men
and we've made that kind of a sort of
thing about oh you know you shouldn't be
seen to you know this thing about in the
swimming pool whatever should you be
seen I don't know these are taking
pictures but she did be swimming too
close to the children it doesn't it
subconsciously you're thinking you know
yeah I can't a little boy walking right
no boy just come up through the trade
come on he's broke was employed just
jumped off with me aside ography I think
we stood before his dad you know what's
going on here you know I saw the second
take you have to take sometimes as I'm
mad when you are around you and we've
got this sort of thing about you know
are you the sort of you know Sutcliffe
you know you can say and and I just
think we've got to kind of be again that
normative thing I think it's an English
thing I do think that we've got to get
back to that kind of sense that we need
we need the male's back in the interplay
yeah you know by you going you know
fathers need to take responsibility they
need to look after children there can't
be this attitude that you know you just
have all the rest of it has it has it
been supportive I've found it quite even
even people I know my own you in my own
family abut we've had big debates about
this they keep saying to me Tony you're
just over simplifying I think those
words over simplifying it it's so many
the problem around life crimes so
complex it's poverty it's that they
didn't get a youth club they you know
it's to do with teachers it and there's
a whole range of things and so what when
people start doing that that long list
shopping list what they're really saying
is back to our thing again it's experts
who don't know see so they've just given
you this long list cuz they don't
because it because that means inaction
because once you start once the list
starts going too fast five things then
you're really say into that boy look we
can't do anything for you you know I
mean and so what they're saying is that
you
you've just come to this problem and
you're just oversimplifying it by just
saying it's about fathers you know yet
the evidence is clear for me that
disproportionately especially if a lot
of black boys are involved in that that
that's that's the issue that they face
and it's not that it might be that knife
crime isn't the problem it might be that
those boys are just unhappy or they're
in that vacuum that moral vacuum that
that means that they then commit that
crime you know and so we've got to look
at the underlying reasons why one of the
things that for me is the key to this is
the way in which we tackled teenage
pregnancy that was a big social problem
I know about you but in London I used to
remember at the time I'm sure it's up
north as well where you'd see all these
teenage girls with these buggies walking
around this on on high yeah we don't see
that anymore you don't see that anymore
not to that extent especially in London
in in in parts of Hackney we've almost
cracked that so what did they do to
develop that war two things girls got a
much more positive image about
themselves and lots more in and that and
and and and and it also coincided to a
certain extent with some of the
positives around social media as well so
that you know it wasn't cool it's not
cool anymore to be a girl with a buggy
walking around town that just doesn't
cut it anymore and um the other thing
was that it was a compulsive compulsive
contraceptives are not telling the
parents that works that seemed to work
as well so yeah the injection went in
and the girls you know let's just stop
them you know I think those two policy
things that that we focused on dealt
with that problem you know it wasn't
cheap we didn't say oh it's too
complicated you know and equally I think
the issue for boys we need a similar
kind of thing around how boys are men
see themselves our fathers see
themselves and making that making it not
cool to be a deadbeat dad almost going
after them really and and then and then
and then and then and then really kind
of almost in a sense sort of saying to
the boys themselves that look here are
some positive
role models and what you can be like as
a as a as a man you know and and putting
that around them so it's a
counter-narrative to the gangs you've
always got to go counter to what you
know the other thing and then you'll get
a positive outcome and it's that kind of
policy thing that you need to start
engineering around those young people
and supporting those single miles
I'm not saying to the single mothers
you've got to stay with those men but at
least do what some other women do at
least call out for help and don't say
you can do it all you know that doesn't
mean that your that doesn't put your
feminism radar lower it just means that
it just means that you're saying that
look I need some support here you know
and we should be able to support those
boys so I do think that we've done it
before and and and we can do it for
young men and tie this is one of the
areas that I really wanted to talk to
you about because it always raises its
head with the police it's stop and
search now lot of people say that it's
it's a racist policy I stopped and
searched for our global audiences where
they say is police stop young men mainly
young black men in searching for knives
and all the rest of it do you agree with
it do disagree with it where do you
stand on it I mean my view on it is
quite an interesting area here because
it's like we've moved to full circle
with it so for example you'd get you get
two voices on this you get people say
our stop and search is bad and it's a
it's oppressive it goes in from one
community but then when there is a knife
crime the police are blamed because
they're not there in it then we're the
police you know and usually get that
from the victims side and it work well
so suddenly we've got a shift in this
and it's it's more towards saying that
okay we need we need more police
so my view on it is I think knife crime
does need quite specific policing I just
think it does it shouldn't he doesn't
need saturating policing what you start
with in the 70s 80s was a crime would be
committed that every black man in the in
a in a variant in the radius of about
five miles was stopped just because you
know you you're just I mean that was
that just caused mass prom I think the
police have got enough intelligence on
this one to be able to do some targeted
things where they know where those those
criminals are
and where they're hanging out and I
think they should use stuff and search
in that that more intelligent way so I
do think you need it we just need to be
done better you know coming back to the
fatherlessness thing one of the things I
found very worrying in the piece that
you had in The Times yeah you talking
about the fact that you're trying to get
this message out there that
fatherlessness is a problem and the
pushback is that a lot of the white
politicians and other people you talk to
they don't want to raise this issue they
don't want to deal with it because of
fear of being called racist yeah right
so how and and and I can't wrap my head
around that that doesn't make sense to
me yeah I mean I think that it was even
worse when I used to come out with stuff
around exclusion from schools and boys
and say the black boys and say that look
this this issue isn't necessarily about
racism but it's actually about some
other things going on in the home in the
peer group and we've got to tackle this
you know and I think equally with with
with the knife crime issue though I
think I must admit there is less of a
there's less of a sense now that people
are I think the more willingness I think
to go to that area now because of the
numbers are so clear that it is
disproportionately black boys are
involved in this however I do think that
when we come to the solutions that
aiming this I mean and my friend David
Lammy is a classic example I mean David
in 2012 he was before me he said you can
just go online just tap in David Lammy
knife crime and up will come all these
articles about him saying black homes
need black fathers I mean states that
you know and and yet now it's sort of
not politically color so correct to do
that
I hear he's roaring back a bit on that
you know he's not coming up and so you
get that sort of sense that there's a
sensitivity around this and nobody wants
to come out and state that as an issue
why and I think that I think it's also
who says it I think it's because there
is a focus on the victim what one it is
is they're saying that the the
that the thing that always helps us out
is the white male if we if we can find
anything to hook it on here it's a get
out of jail card for us yeah so
therefore your screen in this particular
is that see though it what what wait
wait a minute you know we can't we
cannot we cannot blame the victim here
it's got to be something to do with with
with him or at least he's a is is
measures so it's to do with Tory
austerity is to do with the fact isn't a
youth club just to do with the police
you know and the way they see themselves
it's to do with with with white teachers
excluding them from schools anything and
everything but not the hope I think
that's the progress so that's really
worry so but once you start going back
into the home you don't you talk about
agency then you talking about
responsibility of those those
communities and that's that's the
difference you see there nobody wants to
take that especially if you're a
politician who's who's been kind of
almost put up on on the basis that I am
here to protect you from that horrible
world the walls out there that are
coming to get you
so therefore my narrative has always got
to come back to the fact that you're
oppressed not for the fact that the
oppression might be something to do with
what's going on in your home yeah and or
another type of oppression that you
might be perpetuating yourself no you
can't go there and that's where we
that's that's where we've become stuck
but what I think this this issue has
come up is that it as I said I think
that particularly black boys it there a
problem for that kind of rhetoric they
confound that because they as those boys
say look the biggest issue for me was
the fact that my old man left or he
wasn't there or downstairs I was busy
kind of refitting an air gun so that it
could be used as a gun while my daughter
was upstairs doing well my sister was
upstairs doing her work and my dad or
the dads of the three of us the three
different dads just were not here
that's the reality that that I face you
know and so for me that's that's that's
where it it lies and so it's difficult
for communities to come back and say
well we've got to try and sort this out
ourselves you see what I don't
understand there's a guy in America
Larry old I don't know if you live with
him right and Larry he has some
interesting points along the same lines
that you make but he's a guy who just
talks right he's a radio host he's very
articulate very good but he talks right
but you've proven it through the work
that you do and still people are afraid
to say there should be hundreds of
generating geniuses around the country I
think that it yeah there should be and I
think that people are waking up to it
but I think that it's it's a harder one
I mean what's also happened is that the
pot and here's another thing about
generating genus it makes it a little
bit different and people kind of don't
get it a bit is that what it's trying to
do is saturate the mindset of that
community with young people that are
doing very well it's a kind of it's
almost like a kind of counterintuitive
thing because what you usually do in
policies is you go you said to say we're
gonna stack all our resources on on the
very few kids that are causing all this
disruption now admittedly day I mean
when I kill somebody that's a massive
disruption so you've got to do something
but what what we're saying is that
actually what you need to do is you need
to you need to change a narrative around
that group that's what we like what we
did with the teenage girls and so
therefore you you actually may be
needing to sort of go after as I say
children are who are and making sure
that there is that there is a story for
them what what's quite interesting is
that the kids are my program come from
the same schools that the kids who
commit knife crime come from they come
from the same schools so it's not like
they're going off to eat no Harris or
what are the same estates the same
schools yet they're ending up at the top
universities so that that is powerful
you should I mean because you're saying
well they save money the same is the
same lack of youth clubs or ever
austerity they that same and to a
certain extent same lack of fathers
and that's quite interesting as well you
know in their in their homes and yet one
group who is doing well another is and
the other one that confirms it all is
girls at the moment the group that is
doing vest in London are girls from a
West African background and they're
doing really well in school so what
you've got in some homes you've got the
girl upstairs busy doing our work going
off to top university and a boy
downstairs getting ready for prison and
that is happening in a lot of black
homes two pathways for the same kid in
the same household and so that's that's
what your what you're saying is
absolutely right in fact what you need
then is is is is something that's going
to tackle the real core the problem
yeah not pussyfoot around it which is
really what's what's been happening in
the past and it's because we're not
allowing ourselves and this is probably
I've never had this is the most honest
and open conversation I've ever had with
any media on this issue and I've never
heard people talk about it openly
because it's always this oh what should
I say the right thing you know and so we
never get to it no no but it's it's
amazing what you say I mean what part of
this I mean this is that they is is
white guilt where people yeah especially
like you know like what being a white
man you just go I want to ask this
question but is it races if I ask this
question am I making you know just a
general assumption about black people
black men in general am I done my friend
am I gonna get upset and there's also
selfish part of you want all
self-preservation element where you go
well I don't want to address that
because it's just too difficult and too
challenging a subject yeah and I think
that bit about it being too difficult
and challenging the subject is the one
that to me gets in the way but yeah
you're right there's a lot of guilt
running around this thing is that that's
really interesting and guilt in a way is
is difficult I'm having I'm having
difficulties with even films and stories
that keep running the guilt story you
know it to the point where
I think that you the narrative that says
oh you know all these people did this to
me is is interesting and I think to
remind people I started off by telling
you a story of that in that room with
that journalist you know so I'm not
unaware of the the kind of difficulties
that people have in terms of relating to
other groups and women should know that
this is what frustrating for me is that
we're we're right where I see women not
not kind of standing together with me on
this is that they almost can I see their
of their kind of thing is very similar
to black boys you know and we talked
about this in a sense of obsession with
the body the whole thing about
surveillance or whatever lack of
opportunities all these things and then
agency the the ability to sort of see
opportunities and Caeser and go for it
yourself they have similar problems then
yeah they don't then have anything then
I have they have very little empathy
with that because what happens is they
just still go for the default position
that are well you know in the end these
are boys and you feel like they don't
even like boys and I get I get I get a
sense that that's almost what's going on
here that our society our society
doesn't like little boys I mean it kind
of there's a kind of sense that they're
getting the way you know remember if
you're a boy you're gonna have you're
likely to have mom at home her friends
then you go into school you can have a
female teacher you know the whole invite
you heart you you hardly see a man I
would give you a something that's really
interesting you can go to someone some
primary schools now and I just happened
to me a number of occasions you go into
the primary school and suddenly all
these little boys start writing up
writing up towards you it's it's quite
it's quite scary almost like you're
Santa Claus you go oh yeah if they think
that they secretly think you're gonna be
their teacher that's it but it is
really running up to you they talking to
you they cut it cut because if you sit
down with some of those but they
actually do not have any interaction
with any armed male adult Authority none
that's crazy
well Tony it's like you said yourself
it's been a very honest and a very very
young chat we really thank you for
coming on for the work you're doing like
I said I hope that as part of this
conversation or the media to easily do
there are a hundred generating geniuses
around the country eventually thanks
having me question we always ask it's
one which is what is the thing that
people aren't talking about but really
should be well I think we've touched it
one of the things is it's got to be that
the issue about fathers of men really in
the society we've got meaning that we've
got to have a proper grown-up debate
about about that and then come to terms
are there and I think that just debating
honestly what would take us further well
that's been absolutely wonderful thanks
for watching guys as always subscribe to
the youtube channel click the bell
button next to subscribe button so you
get notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word